olivier hahn hon professeur chef de
service à l'hôpital broca paris
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors pourquoi signé une
tribune dans le jdd a qui souhaitez-vous
aujourd'hui faire passer un message
bonjour effectivement là le message il
est il est pour la pour les futurs
patients on va dire pour pour la
population parce que on voit notamment
en ile-de-france une incidence qui
augmente de façon très importante
tournée actuellement à près de près de
600 nouveaux cas pour 100 mille pour
cent mille habitants on était à 350
début le début du mois
début mars donc vrai que cette
augmentation est très importante et du
coup on craint on craint vraiment d'être
débordé qu'il ya un écart entre les
besoins et nos ressources disponibles et
notamment pour les lits de soins
critiques
avec cette augmentation de 2 personnes
qui qui risquent vraiment d'arriver dans
les quinze jours
alors pourquoi on comprenne bien vous
dites bientôt devoir faire le tri parmi
les patients pour sauver des vies qu'est
ce que ça veut dire que selon vos
projections le manque de lits est sûr et
certain
elle voit tout faire on va tout faire
pour bien sûr de ne pas arriver à cette
situation
vous savez qu'il ya énormément de
déprogrammation qui vont se faire pour
essayer de créer d'ouvrir des livres de
200 critique pour prendre en charge on
prendra en charge
bien sûr tous les patients mais ce qu'on
craint c'est qu'à un moment vous voyez
ce n'est plus les ressources disponibles
et que du coup ce moqueries et pas est
un mois terrible hein ce qu'on craint on
va bien sûr prendre en charge tous les
patients
mais ce qu'on ne veut pas c'est arrivé
une situation où on devrait choisir
entre tel patient prise en charge
optimale thèse pas de tels patients pris
en charge un peu moins au petit van ça
on n'est jamais arrivé à 100 et on
arrivé à sale c'est pour ça qu'on alerte
alors vous ne voulez pas arriver à cela
faire ce tri pour le moment on ne sait
rien emmanuel macron larudee dans le
même média dans lequel vous avait
assigné la tribune rien n'est décidé
à l'heure actuelle peut être une prise
de décision mercredi soir lors du
conseil de défense
est ce que ce sera trop tard selon vous
savez que j'ai jamais trop tard bien sûr
donc il faudra plus plus ça va plus ça
va arriver mieux ça sera on n'a pas
encore le recul pour voir ce que vont
donner ces mesures de freinage mais ce
qu'on voit c'est je vous ai dit cette
augmentation absolument très importante
et puis rappelez vous qu'on doit prendre
en charge des patients atteints de l'aco
vide mais on prend aussi en charge des
patients qui ne sont pas atteindre la
queue vide qui ont des maladies comme
d'habitude toutes les maladies
cardiovasculaires neurologiques
les cancers et donc toutes ces patients
là bas il faut s'occuper à la fois des
patients avec l'aco vide sans la copie d
donc pas au bout d'un moment le risque
est qu'on n'est plus assez de lits
suffisant alors vous dites que c'est une
situation inédite pour les hôpitaux même
lors de la première vague lors de
l'année dernière on n'avait pas connu
cette saturation
lors de la première vague on était moins
confronté au fait qu' il y ait des 5es
patients qui n'était pas attendu que
vides
venez - l'hôpital tout on était sur une
situation nouvelle et donc beaucoup de
gens restés à la maison car été aussi
dramatique parce qu'il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas eu une prise en charge
optimale
maintenant on sait qu'on doit prendre en
charge tous les patients qu'ovide non
coheed ce qui fait que ça fait on n'a
pas eu cette situation effectivement
lors de la première de lors de la
première vague donc et en plus cela
proviendrait qu'on avait eu un
confinement qui avait été le plus strict
un confinement que strict aspect c'est
aujourd'hui selon vous est ce qu'il
faudrait faire ça c'est pas aux médecins
de prendre cette décision à nous on est
là pour alerter on se voit que le nombre
de cas augmente on voit nos lits
ne sont pas on peut pas augmenter de
façon importante notre capacitaires et
donc un moment il est d'y avoir un écart
entre le besoin entre la ressource et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on alerte alors
vous êtes médecin vous savez qu'au
niveau du moral des français en font
rejoindre le confinement sans parler de
la précarité économique
est ce que le confinement ne risque-t-il
pas de créer une épidémie de détresse
psychologique au milieu de cette
épidémie de kobe 19 scoci et qu'on est
vraiment dans une situation très
complexe
on peut tout à fait comprendre la
difficulté actuelle et les questions que
tout le monde se pose
mais là c'est vrai que les chiffres
augmentent il ya peut-être d'autres
d'autres façons ou uniquement le
week-end enfin ça c'est pas du tout à
moins de prendre les les décisions il
faut avoir aussi un peu de recul pour
voir quelles ont été les clés
probablement en train d'être fait de
voir l'efficacité de ce nouveau type de
confinement là ce qu'on appelle les
mesures de freinage mais pour l'instant
on voit que ça continue à monter la
grande difficulté par rapport à la
première vague c'est que le virus
vous savez à changer un qui a des
variants et que ce marais anglais qui
maintenant prédominant sur le territoire
est malheureusement beaucoup plus
contagieux que le premier virus saas
comme 2 merci professeur d'avoir répondu
à nos questions olivier ah non je
rappelle que êtes professeur de
cardiologie et maladie vasculaire à
l'hôpital broca de paris et vous êtes
l'un des signataires de la tribune du
jdd merci à vous